you know how you said like let's talk
about something controversial
we could talk about politics but um but
what led me to that is there's this
thing where
you know the country has become
so divided and so partisan that
oddly a bunch of ideas and concepts and
philosophies that aren't directly like
i'm in favor of this sort of bill this
sort of legislation and stuff like that
have been divided and i'll explain
further what i'm talking about what i'm
talking about is
uh i have fed my children and continued
to
raw milk and especially also when i was
having a tough time nursing i was like i
need a backup plan i need some
assistance
my child can't starve while we're
figuring this out
and then also i needed some help when i
was like
working and the baby's still nursing and
so i'm
pumping and we have breast milk but i
also need the raw milk
and then raw milk is just a huge like
it's a huge like like what it gets
categorized on the side
of conservative like
freedom you know freedom from government
regulation and
i don't understand i don't i'm not aware
of this stuff i
understand ryan are you understand you
know about the stuff good uh educate
because i don't know about this
i didn't know there was a sort of a
divide on raw milk
well yeah because categorically it goes
into
the you know natural sort of
um non-medical
non-um mandated vaccines
not it kind of gets lumped over into
this whole side of
governments the government not
controlling what we eat and of course
and what we do to our bodies except for
abortion
that goes on the other side um there's
this weird gerrymandering of ideology
right
but on this side like you have to trace
it back to
okay when i mean do you were you even
aware that milk wasn't raw
uh ryan we weren't aware of that
surprised
right yeah right that's what i always
knew
the milk was pasteurized louis pasteur
invented that
exactly and when louis pasteur invented
it it was for a purpose
it was for killing bacteria whatever
the the outbreak was at the time that
they were addressing that was effective
and so great but
we live in a different time now we don't
have the same issues and the people that
produce
unpasteurized milk take great pride in
the safety measures that they take so
that they can provide it to you and
they're not
exposing you to something you know their
cows are very healthy
this seems so random it's not it's
it's interesting it's a big deal because
in traveling about the country
i have you know there are many states
where they
it's just illegal and then there are
many states where you can get it but
it's
labeled it has to be labeled as for pet
consumption only
and so you have to go like talk to the
farmer and go okay can i
can i buy a gallon of milk like we're
not going to talk about the fact that
i'm going to drink it and my kids are
gonna drink it and they're like yeah
yeah we're
gonna just just take the milk so who
looks down on you
is it is it the democrats or is it the
republicans i can't understand
it's more it's a it's a liberal side of
like trust the science
louis pasteur did this for a reason you
know
the doctors say it's not safe right so
don't drink raw milk you know the and
and they'll tell
pregnant women don't drink raw milk you
could expose yourself to all kinds of
bacteria and
surely that's true or it was
but if you go to the right farmers that
are are
doing it correctly and healthy and and
organically
it's not it was a problem uh many moons
ago before we
uh okay i got you i'm with you it's not
this isn't weird this is educational you
are educating me and my friend ryan and
i'm glad ryan wasn't like of course i
know this because i would have been like
oh
god i'm an idiot i know it is a little
bit
strange um but i always yeah go ahead